période de ponte pour les batraciens il
quitte la forêt pour aller poser leur
jeu dans des étangs il faut les protéger
lorsqu'ils traversent les routes le
département du haut rhin est
particulièrement actif
loïc jfr nous explique comment avec l'un
des spécialistes de la brigade verte
oui car il nous sommes sur le plus grand
site d'alsace en ce qui concerne la
migration des batraciens près de
meyenheim 3300 mètres de grillage et de
seaux pour permettre aux crapauds de
traverser la route sans se faire écraser
depuis ce matin vous le voyez des
bénévoles s'affairent pour permettre aux
crapauds de traverser la route et je
suis avec philippe merkley qui est
coordinateur au niveau du département du
haut rhin pour cette campagne de
migration alors expliquez nous comment
fonctionne d'abord ce système donc le
principe ce sont des filets qui sont mis
temporairement pendant la période de
migration des filets à enterrer avec des
sauts enterré dans lesquelles les
animaux tombe en cherchant à longer le
dispositif donc là les bénévoles
interviennent pour les sauver les
attraper les mettre dans les étangs pour
la reproduction et la manipulation
inverse lorsqu'ils reviennent de l'étang
pour rejoindre leur milieu de vie
et alors le département du haut-rhin et
précurseur en ce qui concerne ses
campagnes de migration des batraciens
oui on est un des premiers départements
en france à l'avoir initié et la sela
29e campagne qui démarre cette année et
c'est important je veux dire c'est la
survie de l'espèce on peut dire
quasiment est en jeu la survie de
l'espèce dépend en partie de ce
dispositif
parce que les crapauds communs comme
vous le savez sont très lents et
traversent les routes très lentement et
on estime que c'est environ 90% de la
population qui est tué en traversant les
routes
donc vous imaginez sur un site comme
maillot naïm qui draine plusieurs
milliers d'animaux par jour vous
imaginez le massacre potentiel voilà
vous l'avez compris une opération
d'envergure l'an dernier par exemple
46000 batraciens ont été récoltés pour
traverser la route en toute sécurité